what if you pulled it and just went
he's like if I gag I gotta give you 25
bucks
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys wow I like that
Order in the Court ordering the court
everybody we got a knife it's loud by
the way that is loud it is like you
don't like it we're supposed to have a
platform but then I lost it a platform
for this yeah well we got tables yeah we
need a platform for it that being said
is that the problem oh that's way better
I'll kind of muted a bit all right
Mr gambini
you can hear a lot of boops
because he had a lot of beats a lot of
boops we make noise okay next door we
make noise
that's what we do that's that's our job
my dad did it my his dad did it that's
what I did when the DJ says Make Some
Noise they talk about me let's talk
about my industry
uh context we're talking about our
neighbors other than that let's talk
about our physical ailments that we may
have experienced in our past present or
whatever so probably the only reason I'm
not a weed head like some people in this
room hey we don't do as much things that
you think that we do that's a fact did
you ever have a dream
we don't do the things that you're
thinking it's just the image the most
boring people that have ever moved to LA
probably is our group but yeah I'm sorry
um to Las Vegas because like Vegas is no
you know the city of sin and all [ __ ]
and it's like before it's like I'm going
to bed at 7 30. and like Joe's like I
don't do any I don't drink and I don't
[ __ ] smoke
uh pretty much you guys fit right in but
no I I smoke like a [ __ ] because
um like we were talking about before I
had whooping cough when I was a teenager
explain to the people that weren't born
during the Great Depression what
whooping cough is right so it's like um
it's well you can look it up um do you
get it from another person oh my god
um we're in a digital age no yeah you
get it from a different person and it
spreads like crazy like it's actually
really really contagious and um it's it
can kill like babies evenly yeah I
remember reading about that yeah go
ahead Anthony whooping cough may begin
like a common cold but unlike a cold the
coughing can last for weeks or months
symptoms of whooping cough usually
develop within five to ten days after
you come into contact with the bacteria
that cause it sometimes symptoms do not
develop for as long as three weeks whoa
so I had it so bad that it did damage to
my lungs so like to this day I can't
inhale certain things like like
cigarettes or wheat blade I can't do it
it'll [ __ ] off like a [ __ ] and um but
you know my one of my favorite comedic
crutches is my Wheezy laugh which I use
for hacky humor and then the reason why
I start hacking after that is because I
had whipping coughs like my lungs were
[ __ ] with but then like it yeah it
sounds rough eventually but that's why
so yeah um but yeah it sucked because
um coming out of that like I had
whooping cough and then like I was doing
improv at the time and
we would always laugh like because we're
doing improv and we would all break on
stage and all kinds of hacky stupid [ __ ]
that you shouldn't do because you're
Pros but you do because
you know you see your guy next to you
you respect so much and he's laughing
and you [ __ ] bow stuff and then you
guys are Wheezy laughing and probably
the audience doesn't even care and
probably hates you for it yeah they want
to leave and they're like [ __ ]
looking at their watches like with
they're looking at their watch and their
[ __ ] pocket watch and like they're
[ __ ] they got like seven watches
they're looking at while you guys are
like making to the laugh on stage good
for you you suck
um but trauma there huh but the coughing
was crazy during that like because I
would cough and people would think I was
sick and I wasn't I was sick like months
and months ago but oh yeah so so
laughing too much would do that to me so
laughing is my curse please don't make
me laugh if if it's medically it brings
it back yeah really medically my how did
you know that it was whooping cough did
you go to the hospital yeah I was
diagnosed with it
I wonder did you ever find out who gave
it to you yeah it was my uh improv
Mentor at the time oh [ __ ] no way you
actually know yeah wow because he was
dying laughing is his curse too it's not
just bronchitis you want to go in for a
re-diagnosis at this age
so I had some major bronchitis in 2019
right before lockdown in February right
and I remember the news talking about
covid and stuff the Corona and then I
asked at the Urgent Care I'm like oh I
just had this crazy session like I have
to get pills and all that and they're
like no that just sounds like a bad case
of bronchitis it's probably not covered
so I had that too because we both got it
from the same launch party but
um it was different than whooping cough
because whooping cough I couldn't
breathe in a certain amount without
coughing but with this one it was
completely different as far as like I
was just coughing off cough like it had
nothing to do with like breathing in and
then coughing can you do scuba I'm a
certified scuba diver so yeah that
wasn't a problem having going to get the
certification no no never was a problem
my loan capacity is actually pretty good
it's just that there was damage done so
a certain amount of whatever you just
can't get through you shouldn't put
toxins in your lungs basically just not
you just can't get through a whole
Rodney Dangerfield movie I'll die so
there's no way to heal your lungs from
that
like eating bananas I think your God God
can do that yeah right yeah my thoughts
and prayer it out of me maybe we'll give
you some thoughts and prayers you ever
tried Wim Hof
no what is that again that is what I do
when I was doing cold training and
breathing exercises to hold my breath
there's like a lot of people that had
like lung issues and like just different
health issues that when they did that
technique it helped them out really no
[ __ ] you should like YouTube just
like an intro Wim hofting and try to
just uh experience it one time you
basically hyperventilating we should do
it together but do it gonna be cold for
long no no no it's not even close enough
just to breathing you could like just
lay down in a comfortable spot yeah you
breathe in a certain way like you uh
inhale strongly through your mouth
starting from your gut by pushing your
stomach out and all the way until you
feel air going to your head the second
inhale as much as you can up to there
you exhale as if you don't care so it's
like
and you just keep doing it okay like 15
30 times something and then on the last
one you hold your breath and no [ __ ] you
can hold it for like over two minutes I
can already do that though [ __ ] do
it right now no no
see two minutes of interesting but like
just doing that even from an intro level
doing that over and over it like
oxygenates like the rest of your body
you feel like tingling in different
places and stuff and it actually does
help you with the cold training [ __ ]
works I know that because like anytime I
do a cold shower I'm like whoa I'm like
[ __ ] awake and my fingertips yeah I
love doing that I think that shit's real
I'm too [ __ ] to do it but when I do it
it's great I know I hate being cold for
long but I'm like oh this is good in the
morning is hard I only enjoy cold
showers on hot days yeah it's already
after a workout yeah I'm a big tough guy
when it's hot and it's like yeah the
worst thing when you wake up and you're
already cold and then you get out of
your warm blankets and then you're like
let's go anybody else physical ailments
I grew up with so many things that my
parents thought that I was gonna not
survive
they bet against you
I had like do you tell stomach issues I
had pneumonia once I was hospitalized
multiple times I was allergic to
everything as soon as I was born
um they found out like a little bit
later when I started eating solids like
when I was eating rice I had all like
this crazy breakout and then they took
me to the hospital and they're like yeah
he can't eat rice he can't eat milk so
basically I grew up paleo before what
paleo was wow just meat and veggies and
then slowly I was able to introduce
grains
like I couldn't eat egg like I well I
could eat yolk I can't eat the white
whoa yeah I couldn't eat cereals I
couldn't eat a lot of stuff or else I
break out like crazy and then feel sick
like eczema yeah like my Eczema was bad
it's it's head to toe and it's genetic
too because my one of my other nephews
has the same thing and then
um
yeah I just I was always getting sick
too like going to the hospital for
different reasons
never broke a bone but it was always
like intestine issues stomach issue or
like some kind of you know lung
bronchitis whatever every year and then
I just stopped getting sick like around
the times I started doing a lot of drugs
like I became like homeless immune like
I'd be sleeping three hours a night or
whatever eating whatever people gave me
with my friends and just out and about
whatever people get yeah literally like
I would just be crashing at my friend's
house for like a while just eating their
food and then we go to the next house
and then so like the goal of the day was
how high can we get like that was
probably most of my high school
and then around that time like I would
get like the flu and I'm like coughing
vomiting and then they're like let's go
Rave and I'm like [ __ ] yeah so we go to
like Master Dome and [ __ ] get rolled
like we're just popping E pills while
I'm like when I have a fever I'm out
here doing a NordicTrack dancing my
[ __ ] fever away the next day I'm fine
I wake up and I'm not vomiting anymore I
don't have any like fever do you think
it was the thing that's like hey dude if
you go to this event you're gonna get
the flu every time because Joe's is
there
it's like everyone just knows you're
gonna get the flu but it's great it's
great you know Joe comes back he's like
I'm fine everybody has some flu now
what's wrong with you guys Master them
Master Dome it used to be this the wrist
area and um Riverside you know what's
[ __ ] crazy right so you know Event
Photography yeah like they would go out
and take pictures of the Raves and
whatever and I was curious one day and
there are photos of me at like yeah I
was here 13 years old rolling
with my friends like on ecstasy at
there's yeah it's on the forums out
there wow yeah 13. yeah but but I think
that was the time when I stopped being
sick all the time and then like all into
being an adult now like I don't know I'm
never sick
and then like nothing affects me I had
kova and it just I just lost taste and
that was it same yeah maybe I just been
so sick that I have I'm like a doctor
with all this disease in me already like
I'm immune because you have cultures of
different yeah well the first time when
you and me had meme covet when everyone
said we didn't have kovid yet because
it's not con that was 2019. that was
brutal but that was actually confirmed
later to be the first wave of covid
which we had which was brutal but then
the part where everyone's like you had
accepted covid okay that's fine you can
say you had coveted here that was a
piece of cake yeah that the December one
that we had in was it 2020
easy mode I just lost taste that was it
easiest [ __ ] ever I didn't even know and
I
it's a negative too I had worse date I
had worse nice doing Improv
doing a bad show
that was crazy yeah I had a thing uh in
20 I want to say like
2010 or 2009 or something like that
um I started developing these like uh
what were called body abscesses just
like on the sides it's like a giant
pimple but it wouldn't be like a shallow
one it would like uh just flare up or
get infected so to speak right and in
one case too like boils kind of [ __ ] in
one case I got on my elbow it's right
here as you can see
um I went to three different like
doctors including like skin people and
stuff like that and then people kept on
saying like oh we don't know what it is
but it must be like an immunodeficiency
or something like that so they give me
like all these like random uh you know
suggestions for lifestyle changes I
entered a phase where I didn't drink I
didn't smoke uh for like eight months I
slept I made sure I had to sleep for
eight hours I showered twice a day I
like didn't do a bunch of different
things
um but I would just like get them and uh
one time uh when I got it on my elbow I
went to Vegas and I was partying stuff
because I was like [ __ ] it you don't
know what this is anymore
um being stupid as it was and it got
super infected to the point where this
little thing
grew here and then it went all the way
literally from here it went all the way
to my four uh like my wrist area and it
was just and I couldn't bend my arm damn
so I finally go to urgent care it was my
first time I've never been to like a
hospital I never had to go through
surgery I never broke a bone or anything
this is right I came back oh I go to
urgent care and then they basically have
to uh cut it open and then the doctor
and the nurse are just squeezing
yeah I wish I could watch it too could
you smell it
uh I don't fully recall
white pus not really actually yeah just
like plasma and pus right and it was so
much that it's one of those things that
I never [ __ ] understood this
experience before after they fully
squeeze it out they take like this
almost like a um almost like a clown's
balloon that's like hella long and thin
and they they shove it in
they just keep on pushing it in like
this like little [ __ ] rubber thing
I'm like what is that they're like it's
the collect uh the plasma plus that
you're gonna keep creating and then you
got to come back in like a week or
whatever we'll pull it out oh I was like
okay so we shoved this like whole thing
in there oh it's like a vacuum bag gauze
it up yeah why do they need to do that
like don't you naturally create that to
like protect like I think when it's
infected like like I'm almost over
creating it and it's like to combat it
all right right and then I had to go
back a week later or whatever they cut
it they pulled the whole end I remember
when they were pulling it out to what a
sensation to just have like a plus full
balloon I've been there slowly being
really different part of my body out of
my penis
not kidding no way when I had kidney
stones I don't want to take it from here
oh yeah yeah I can't wait to get to the
story yeah so they just pull it out
no that sensation though is [ __ ] yeah
it was what would you compare it to
because I'm sure there's nothing you
could really compare it to though but oh
my God best guess
um
you ever uh eat spaghetti and laugh and
sneeze and then
oh [ __ ] wow that's really good that's
actually better than I could ever yeah
it's just such a weird obstruction and
it's just like uh it just lasts so long
it's just a feeling like what the [ __ ]
yeah that's when I had my kidney stones
right they had to blast it out with a
laser very quick and then um they
blasted with the laser but then they put
a stent in me to collect a stent is like
it's gonna it's a little um plastic
container that's gonna collect all the
particulates so that there's not going
to be more mineral buildup fragments no
fragments because they blew it up but
they didn't get out all of it oh okay so
there might be more fragments and then
this will collect them so that they can
in your in my bladder side of my body
right so they cut you up and they stick
that in yeah so that doesn't redeposit
yes and then they have the so the scent
is there to re to collect all that stuff
that will go through my urethra
eventually but it won't make it there
because this is in the way and then
um there was a string coming out of my
dick for like four days
where
um and it was and I I stringy dick
because I had to I had to think wow
so you look like a candle it's not a
string it's not a string so it's like a
tampon yeah no it was like a candle
exactly it's like but you're so you're
like a little Wick it would dude it was
[ __ ] wild because I got out of
surgery and then like this is part of my
body now it's like weird but then days
later I I just go in for like they're
like hey we're gonna remove the scent
today and then you're just thinking like
okay well I just went in for surgery it
was like [ __ ] crazy they had to put
me under all this stuff and then like
okay hey
um Mr Green stent removal awesome come
with me and then I go in there and then
I'm in there with them and the doctor's
like who wants to take down your pants
somebody cool take another pants and
he's like he's like yeah so um anyway
and he grabs the string and he just
[ __ ] Yanks it out of me and I and
he's just pulling and pulling and this
thing's like long guys
[Music]
no we got any noodle out of the nose and
I it was like it was like this it was
like I was like ah and I was like uh but
I you know I didn't take it like a [ __ ]
I was like
[Music]
and I grabbed the guy's shoulder like
that so he had your shoulder you had his
shoulder yeah yeah and it was just like
a little bit like that and then it was
and then it was done but then I saw this
[ __ ] thing flapping out of my body it
was like what the [ __ ] what what did
they do to me what if he pulled it and
just went
if I gag I gotta give you 25 bucks
I'd be like don't waste it don't you
[ __ ] waste that what's wrong with
[ __ ] I'd say swallow it [ __ ] face
you'd be like doctor what the [ __ ] the
best part is the sound
he's gonna love these
best part of my day come back next time
that's [ __ ] wild so you guys are just
the pillars of perfect health or what no
not at all I have endometriosis
what is that so that's a that's a tough
one it's yeah it's rough so I struggle
with that but the last five to six
months have been progressively better
because I've been doing my own research
and biohacking uh but basically it's
where tissue goes on the outside of your
uterus or various areas and cysts form
and sometimes they rupture and so when I
have my internal cysts yes so when I
have my menstrual cycle this is when
this happens and the pain is yeah
the pain is
the pain is it's not too bad I got you
it's not too bad it's not too bad it's
not too bad it's not it's no stringy
dick but it's uh you know it's not too
bad is that the same thing as ovarian
cyst
um there are different categories but
similar oh [ __ ] but it's it's so bad
that sometimes when a cyst ruptures I'll
pass out whoa what the [ __ ] yeah this is
actually yesterday guys
you passed out yesterday
um yeah what do you mean like is anyone
like if you're alone you just pass out
and you get back up and you're like so
the pain is is so heavy that your body
goes into shock and you end up throwing
up and then to the point where you have
nothing left in your system and then
you're in so much shock that you pass
out and the pain is that heavy that you
wake yourself back up into it
cycle that is torture for like a good
for me particularly it's like
36 hours straight
just in bed and just like
just trying to make who's taking care of
you yeah
um myself what the [ __ ] dude you should
have someone nearby right yeah oh my God
if only you had somebody out there that
could save you oh God you're gonna her
inbox is already full I love you you
need a man who doesn't have too many
muscles because you don't need all that
that's just vain right yeah that's all
like your own personal vanity and
[ __ ] I have I have people that take
care of it there's no treatment for it
um no there is no cure and any doctor
that I ever go to is like oh it's just
really bad cramps oh um I'm like first
off [ __ ] you uh oh wow their their
solution is to take birth control I've
heard of that it's like it's not a
solution yeah everyone's on birth
control when they have ovarian sister
it's it's a Band-Aid yeah does it help
or it doesn't do [ __ ] well because the
the point of taking birth control uh is
to stop your menstrual cycle so if you
don't have your menstrual cycle then
don't go into the situation I see but
the majority of people who end up taking
birth control over a long period of time
they
they have a worse situation after they
get off yeah there's like fertility
issues fertility there's a bunch of
complications there's like this whole
movie not a solution
um are you trying to have a baby because
I think a lot of people might want to
help you with that
[Laughter]
we'll find you a shooter somebody people
are going to help you they're really
good they're really very huge male fan
base yeah look almost too big and that
means you have not not big but height
it's like this
interrupts my life a lot the last five
six months have been a lot better yeah
just because I feel like I've gone
through my own medical school just to
find a solution for this yeah and that's
what usually happens and biohacking with
food and exercise during certain times
of the day and throughout the month
changes that however
um I remember being on set and I'm
filming and I get it oh nobody and
that's that's the problem it's like
there's nobody that can cover me it's a
15-hour day
um what do you do yeah
I just sucked it up holy [ __ ] that's
crazy so like I'm like shaking like
probably gonna
just like let's go let's get this
[ __ ] shot what's the rate what's the
rate of occurrence nowadays for when
that happens like on average so far so
the pain level nowadays like
like four it was like
it was 11 out of 10. and I have a pretty
high pain tolerance yeah it's pretty bad
um now I would say it varies between
like yesterday the last day and a half
was like
six seven oh [ __ ] wow so you really did
biohack it down a little bit yeah and
it's like every every menstrual cycle
every month
every month I'm playing
and is so sweet during her period what's
everybody else's yeah let's go what's
your excuse me
I'm so grateful for the fact that I can
you're alive walk wow and just eat or
just drink water again like I'm just so
grateful for that that I'm just like I'm
in a great mood dude I wish my wife
could suck it up like you
tell me about this video tell me about
it brother you know what Colleen has to
go through yeah yeah guess what our
friends she biohacked it herself yeah
yeah
somebody else and it was a woman who
also went through that so she gave you
some tips so I read her book and I was
like oh [ __ ] like I've even done like
um
these uh neurostimulators too to like oh
block the pain receptors from going to
your brain I've done so many things wow
oh my gosh I like the idea of using her
as an example next time someone's
bitching and be like you have an idea
Colleen's got mesothelioma
did you say the wrong [ __ ] she's got
juice
she's got Muzzy I know she does she told
me she's got syphilis okay
that one may not know all right thank
you so much
[Music]
foreign
[Music]